hello again two british and one
irish national are amongst those who
have been rescued from an ongoing
operation against rebels in palmer in
northern mozambique we're joined now by
meryl knox her 40 year old son adrian
nell died
in an attack by the militants good
afternoon to you thank you for joining
us at
what is clearly a very difficult time
our condolences
to you um i wonder if you could take us
back and tell us what adrian was doing
in mozambique
adrian was working as a contractor
helping to build an accommodation camp
and he'd been there for a while had he
he had only been there since
uh about the 8th of january
right and obviously we know that uh
rebels the insurgents have
stormed this town of palmer and adrian
was there was he
yes he was um and
he him and my husband
and my younger son were
in a hotel called the amarula which was
meant to be a safe place
waiting to be evacuated from wednesday
afternoon when the attacks started
have they always been in the hotel
before that then
no not at all they were staying in the
accommodation camp that they were
building not too far from the hotel
and so what do you know of the attack
that happened on wednesday this
onslaught by the insurgents
i just got news that there had been an
attack
and um then we couldn't get hold of
anybody on the cell phones um
eventually at nine o'clock on wednesday
night my husband managed to contact me
by a settler phone
to let me know what was going on and he
said they were in this hotel it was safe
and arrangements were going to be made
for them to be evacuated
that was on wednesday and what
subsequently happened
well thursday came and went
thursday afternoon we heard that
the evacuations had started
and i think women and children were
first being evacuated
and then obviously it only started late
in the afternoon and the helicopters
couldn't fly at night
and um then we we heard
there was horrific farting going on
and it wasn't safe for any further
evacuations
so they were all in the hotel at this
time still were they
yes i believe they were 190 people in
the hotel
from all different nationalities
so that was that takes us to thursday
and then
what happened after that on friday that
was the key day wasn't it
yes friday they got word um the last
thing i heard was
at thomas land my youngest son messaged
me to tell me
they're waiting to be evacuated
and that was the last we heard from them
who was going to help in this evacuation
process do you know
well you know it's been so difficult to
find
out what really was going on there i
managed to get onto a local whatsapp
group
who did provide information
and they did then
you know i saw that there was a message
for these guys
because evacuation by helicopter wasn't
going to happen
the insurgents had surrounded the hotel
and the only chance they had of getting
away was to
do a convoy so
your family was in this convoy is that
right yes
yes and it was a large convoy we're led
to believe
um a number of vehicles involved i
believe so yes
and apparently as they were about
or when they were driving out
unfortunately
the insurgents ambushed them and my son
was shot
was he in the convoy were they all
together the
your family yes my husband my youngest
son
adrian and a friend were in the one con
so your husband and son would have
witnessed what happened
yes they did yeah
what was the first you learned about
anything that had happened
i learned on friday night that
people had been killed as they tried to
leave the hotel
and we didn't hear who had been killed
um so it was only on saturday morning
that i got news that unfortunately it
was adrian
and what happened to your husband and
other son were they wounded
they weren't wounded they managed to get
away i'm not too sure of
the details they are too traumatized to
go through this right now and they
managed to get away
they were told to go and meet up at
what's called the lighthouse
i believe on the way to tanzania which
is not too far
up the road and um then
they were also told that they need
satellite phones to phone the army camp
there to let them know otherwise they
are going to get shot at
from there so they decided to
go somewhere else i have an
idea they may have gone into the bush
somewhere and
obviously just had to wait until they
were rescued
saturday morning
a great deal of uh uncertain time you've
lost
one son and not knowing what's happening
to the rest of your family
yeah absolutely um
you know it's terrible when you hear
this and you can't get confirmation
of who's being killed or whether your
family are safe
or in actual fact what whatever has
happened there
well what's the current situation
regarding your husband and son
are you aware yes i am i have spoken to
my husband
my son is very traumatized as is i'm
sure my husband but he's
being very strong and luckily they were
able to
bring adrian's body back to pember with
them
so they just waiting for that
all the paperwork to be done so we can
get them back to south africa
tell us about adrian was he out there
just wanting to help others basically as
the rest of your family
adrian was a very joyful person
he brought love and kindness and joy to
anyone and everybody he met he has
many many friends all over the world
relatives just love him to
pieces he's he's just the heart of the
family and like i said the ray of
sunshine when adrian walked in the room
you were automatically happy
clearly a very very distressing time for
you there are people
still i gather in the hotel waiting
to be rescued now and your thoughts
would go out to them
absolutely this is one of the reasons i
decided to do interviews
was for the people that have relatives
there that they are still
not sharing what's happened to them
they're still looking for their loved
ones
and like i said not much help is coming
from the mozambique side
and yeah i just feel this whole thing
could have been avoided it's not like
it's something out of the blue this has
happened close to palma
in the not too dis recent past
and the insurgents actually
did send flyers out a little while ago
to say that they were going to attack
the town
so what has gone wrong then in your
opinion
well firstly the mozambican army
i believe have been there to mostly
protect the
the gas plot and
i don't think that they requested any
other outside help
um there is a private security company
there that's contracted to them and
thank goodness for that otherwise we
wouldn't have anybody
left there because the helicopters had
been going and trying to
get the the insurgents
uh to leave or to you know to get rid of
them
could this situation have been foreseen
therefore do you believe or or is it
simply a matter of the insurgents
suddenly
taking over on on one day no definitely
i mean it wasn't
too many weeks ago i think that they
checked a village about 20 kilometers
away
and believe me
they they make sure that they leave
nobody
unharmed what are your feelings towards
the authorities at this
painful time well i just
feel that my son shouldn't have died
there should have been
more help and
i believe the muslim beacon army
didn't try and protect them and i just
can't see
how supposedly we were told there were
100
insurgents that an army
couldn't contain him
if the so much instability in the region
is it regarded had it previously been
regarded as safe and somewhere that that
britons could go
people from different nationalities
we're here so many people from different
countries have been caught up in this
crisis
yeah well you know with the the big oil
company
uh gas company their total you
should think that there are enough army
and security personnel to protect us
along with all the people working around
there
yet total now we know they have
postponed their work this
huge gas facility so what does that tell
you
well yes that is that i i
do believe that they had postponed it
and told the muslim economy to get the
act together
and on the day the attacks started they
signed an agreement to resume
work if you've got one message for the
mozambican authorities what would it be
it would be please you should have
actually
had a better army you should have
actually called your neighbours for help
or the international community crimes
against humanity have been committed
here
horrific crimes against humanity
and also to your own mozambican people
why have you just left this to carry on
for years